quand on pense au monde de l'entreprise
on pense souvent aux 4 40 ses grandes et
puissantes entreprises
or en france on le sait peu mais les
sociétés les plus répandues ce sont des
tpe très petites entreprises
on en compte deux millions en france des
structures avec moins de 10 salariés
il faut savoir qu'en franche-comté une
entreprise sur deux est une aux tpe
principal secteur d'activité la
construction et le commerce en détails
et on compte aussi dans notre région une
très grande part de tpe dans la
restauration et les services aux
personnes
ces entreprises on les trouve dans les
grandes villes de la région bien sûr
dijon besançon chalon belfort
montbéliard mais aussi et c'est tout
l'intérêt dans les zones moins
urbanisées où elles maintiennent
l'emploi c'est le cas dans le morvan le
châtillonnais ou encore dans le secteur
de caunes clemessy alors entreprendre en
milieu rural est il plus facile qu'à la
ville non répondent les petits patrons
qui se sentent délaissés par le
gouvernement dans une étude récente 55 %
d'entre eux affirment ne pas percevoir
pour leur entreprise le bénéfice de
l'action publique